[Música]
hoy vamos a hablar de este
fake news
leyenda urbana que la definición
académica es historia inventada
extravagante que circula entre la gente
como si fuera verdadera yo diría que
exagera malintencionada y que
normalmente lleva una carga de cálculo
para tratar de generarle daño a alguien
o tratar de beneficiar indebidamente a
alguien y hoy vamos a hablar de las de
las leyendas urbanas de las face news
relacionadas con el proyecto perdón con
la ley de fortalecimiento de las
finanzas de las finanzas públicas pero
antes de entrar específicamente en las
leyendas urbanas de la ley de
fortalecimiento deberíamos de hablar del
período anterior a la aprobación del
proyecto es que pasamos 18 años tratando
de aprobar una reforma fiscal en costa
rica
entonces la leyenda urbana la mentirosa
era que nosotros los que nos dedicamos
impuestos éramos algo así como el
pastorcillo mentiroso ya la van a
aprobar
en esta vez sí y al final terminó
muriendo y muriendo dos reformas en la
sala este constitucional lo que no era
una leyenda urbana era la actitud de
muchos sectores y grupos de interés en
el país cuando hacían un análisis de la
situación macroeconómica decían con cara
compungida y esto lo hago parafraseando
un amigo economista decían estamos
jodidos todos ustedes y cuando se
hablaba específicamente de medidas en el
campo de impuestos para solucionar los
problemas decían parafraseando al mismo
economista tenemos que pagar todos
ustedes por igual entonces eso fue lo
que ocurrió en este país por muchísimos
años
a partir de diciembre y específicamente
la entrada en vigencia en julio de este
año tenemos la ley de fortalecimiento de
las finanzas públicas pero antes y
prometo que ya comienzo con las técnicas
relacionadas con la ley quisiera hablar
de una leyenda urbana que hace daño una
fein yus que flota en el ambiente y es
la que dice que los empresarios son los
grandes evasores y específicamente habla
de que los grandes contribuyentes son
los grandes evasores del país y yo
pregunto cómo puede alguien que es gran
contribuyente es el gran invasor
si nosotros pensamos que los grandes
contribuyentes en este país significan
el 67 por ciento de la recaudación de
impuestos sobre la renta y que si a esto
le unimos lo relacionado con las grandes
empresas territoriales y llegamos casi a
un 78 por ciento de la recaudación de
impuestos sobre las utilidades no les
parece que eso es una leyenda urbana una
noticia falsa que flota en el ambiente y
que desafortunadamente los
costarricenses han comenzado a creer
y esto no es de todo el proceso de
aprobación de la reforma ni de lo que
está ocurriendo en este momento
pero bueno
y esto tiene que ver precisamente el
tema de los grandes contribuyentes con
cazar en el zoológico porque al rato la
gente de la administración tributaria se
va por la ley del mínimo esfuerzo y
entonces casi que tienen oficinas fijas
en las empresas que son grandes
contribuyentes y grandes empresas
regionales y esas son a las que
básicamente fiscalizan que me perdón
administrada hacienda y no hacen el
esfuerzo que se requiera que se requiere
en sacar de la informalidad a gente que
gana muchísimo dinero que son malos
empresarios que compiten deslealmente y
que son realmente los evasores de este
país pero comencemos con las mentirillas
lo primero que era un paquetazo de
impuestos
si vemos el producto de la reforma para
los siguientes 4 años el 60 y algo por
ciento del producto de la reforma está
relacionado con regla fiscal y el
componente de empleo público y un 30 y
algo por ciento en materia de ingresos
que en este momento ni siquiera se
acerca de ese treinta y algo por ciento
porque recuerden que tenemos tarifas
escalonadas y regímenes de exención que
desafortunadamente todavía siguen
funcionando eran paquetazos de impuestos
las reformas que afortunada o
desafortunadamente murieron fueron
suicidas asesinadas en la sala
constitucional
otro de los mitos es que los salarios
iban a quedar grabados conmigo entonces
que los trabajadores y así se asustaba
muchísima gente iban a tener que pagar
iba por el componente de salarios lo que
sí es cierto es que la reforma hizo
menos regresivo el componente de
impuesto sobre las utilidades creando
dos tarifas adicionales que a mí en lo
personal me duelen muchísimo en lo
personal del 20 y el 25 por ciento para
los salarios más altos y con esto se
eliminó la gran regresividad donde una
persona con 2 millones y algo de colones
pagaba el mismo 15 por ciento de una
persona que ganaba 10 millones de
colones
la electricidad grabada como gran
noticia y gran innovación del proyecto
fortalecimiento de las finanzas públicas
la electricidad de estado gravada con
impuestos de ventas desde siempre y el
tramo exento con la reforma más bien
amplió el nivel de consumo para los
hogares estén menos favorecidos de este
país
la educación universitaria grabada y
cuando hablamos de la educación grabada
estamos se dijo que la educación
secundaria la primaria que todo iba a
estar grabado con el 2% y eso es
absolutamente falso la educación
regulada esté exenta y la educación no
regulada está gravada con un 2% ahora
bien
hay dudas que se generan por cuanto lo
que no es educación
y regulaba como les digo con el 2% pero
hay una excepción a todo lo que tenga
que ver con clases de deporte y eso sí
quedó grabado un 13 por ciento en miami
y ahí se me se me ofrece una duda de
rocío de carácter académico este yo no
he logrado definir todavía y la verdad
es que le ha metido mucha cabeza si las
clases de paul dancing se pueden este
determinar como clases de deporte o
clases de carácter cultural grabadas con
el 2 por ciento pero todo ese tipo de
cosas que vamos a tener que ir
dilucidando conforme avancemos en la
aplicación de la ley
en el caso de las zonas francas se dijo
que la ley iba a destruir el régimen de
zonas francas que se iba a gravar con
impuestos sobre las utilidades que se
iba a grabar con iva y que las empresas
iban a caer en un estado de estampida de
este país es absolutamente falso el
régimen de zonas francas no se tocó
dentro del proyecto de fortalecimiento
de las finanzas públicas y más bien
recientemente en una modificación de la
ley se rompió el límite de ventas
locales tanto para bienes como servicios
dentro del país
en cuanto en cuanto a las pymes se dijo
que eran los grandes perdedores de la
reforma que la reforma estaba hecha
básicamente para empresas grandes este
para esos entre comillas grandes
evasores y eso es absolutamente falso
las pymes tienen un régimen diferenciado
sosteniendo todavía el régimen
simplificado y tienen un tratamiento
diferenciado también en lo que se
refiere a alquileres que lo vamos a
pasar a ver pronto además después de la
entrada en vigencia de la reforma el
ministerio de hacienda ha hecho un
esfuerzo significativo en materia de
formularios informativos de
declaraciones facilitando la vida dentro
del iva a las pequeñas medianas y micro
empresas de este de este país
había uno que era simpatiquísimo ahora
que yo creo que no merece mayor
comentario pero la ley establece que se
está modificando el impuesto general
sobre las ventas y esto le permitió
incluso algunos diputados porque las
noticias falsas se generan muchísimo en
la asamblea legislativa es decir que la
tarifa iba a ser de un 26% sumando 13
más 13
desafortunadamente no es así
los alquileres los alquileres gravados
en efecto los alquileres se grabaron
pero tenemos que recordar que los
alquileres residenciales inferiores a
669 mil colones está excento y eso es un
componente de más del 90 por ciento de
los ingresos por alquileres en el país e
igual en alquileres comerciales pymes
inscritas en el ministerio de economía o
inscritas en el ministerio de
agricultura están exentos de hasta los
669 mil colones y lo importante es que
los alquileres funcionan como crédito
entonces cuando la gente decía que los
los centros comerciales iba a quebrar
porque tenían que pagar iva se les
olvidaba que se iba que pagaban lo iban
a poder acreditar contra la venta de
mercancías que ya de por sí está gravado
con impuestos de ventas
que el agua está grabada el agua está
grabada desde el impuesto de eventos y
el nivel de consumo se mantiene
exactamente igual en el proyecto de
fortalecimiento de las finanzas públicas
renta mundial y vamos a pasar la renta
mundial y es que la gente tiende a
confundir renta global con renta mundial
el proyecto no cambió en nada la
territorialidad de la fuente
costarricense renta global es otra cosa
es meter en una misma canasta diferentes
fuentes de ingresos diferentes fuentes
de riqueza dado que nosotros lo que
tenemos es un impuesto de carácter
celular lo que quiero que quede claro es
que no hay renta mundial en costa rica y
la renta mundial es cualquier cosa menos
globalizar el impuesto sobre las
utilidades
es una reforma es regresiva cualquier
impuesto de carácter indirecto tiende a
ser regresivo pero la reforma y esto no
es una apología de la de la reforma pero
las cosas hay que decirlas tal y como
son eliminó una serie de sesgos que
existían en el pasado en el impuesto
general sobre las ventas por ejemplo
la canasta básica que de básica no tenía
absolutamente nada era producto de
decisiones políticas y presiones de
grupo la canasta que tenemos hoy y este
es un ejemplo nada más obedece al 11 a
los hábitos de consumo del quintil más
pobre de la población costarricense de
forma tal que se dejó de exonerar este
producto de consumo que sólo estaban
dentro de las compras del consumo de las
clases más favorecidas
y tarifas reducidas una ventaja como ya
se me está yendo el tiempo lo voy a
tratar de graficar con un ejemplo la
gente creyó que bien negociar tarifas
diferenciadas era lo importante y se les
olvidó que los créditos funcionan en
función de la tarifa le voy a poner un
ejemplo que es muy muy sencillo resulta
hacer que los seguros personales vida
salud esté quedaron con un 2 por ciento
y todo el mundo salió feliz de la
asamblea legislativa porque hayan
logrado un 2 por ciento se les olvidó
que no habían negociado el tema del
crédito y resulta ser que el 85 por
ciento del costo los seguros personales
son los reaseguros y los reaseguros
quedaron en el 13 entonces de ese 13 que
en el 85 por ciento sólo pueden
acreditar un 2 por ciento entonces hay
un 11 por ciento que va a tener que ir o
al costo va a tener contra la utilidad
oa tener que trasladarse al consumidor
final entonces el tema de las tarifas y
el crédito de lado si ganás relacionado
con las tarifas lo que ha convertido es
una pesadilla en él
de construcción en el sector de turismo
donde lo lógico son - exoneraciones y
una tarifa uniforme para la totalidad de
los bienes y la totalidad de los
servicios algunos lo hicieron bien zona
franca municipalidades universidades el
régimen de exportación pero hay una
verdadera pesadilla en algunos sectores
al momento de aplicar la
proporcionalidad en función de las
tarifas diferenciadas
hay una hay una que si a mí realmente me
molesta en la misma línea de que los
grandes evasores y los grandes
contribuyentes que los bancos resulta
ser que son los más beneficiados con la
reforma y resulta ser que el único
sector globalizado en impuestos sobre la
renta son los bancos entonces resulta
ser que los rendimientos en certificados
de inversión en cualquier instrumento de
los bancos no están al 15% como todos
los demás mortales que no tenemos la
renta globalizada sino que como todos
ustedes saben lo tienen que integrar al
30% y además de eso la gran mayoría de
los servicios de los bancos empezando
por los intereses están exentos de iva
entonces los bancos tienen un problema
terrible por todo el iva que soportan
todos los meses y no tienen contra que
acreditarlo lo cual si bien puede
significar una devolución de un momento
es un tema complicado de flujo de caja
entonces es decir que los bancos son los
principales beneficiarios de la reforma
y ya pasó un poquito de noticia
a infamia
y para terminar con el tema del déficit
fiscal este en la parte de ingresos es
como una curita
no es suficiente y les recuerdo que
estamos hablando de impuestos que
incomodan chimán molestan pero lo cierto
es que con esto no vamos a salir
adelante la tarifa del 13 por ciento y
sé que no soy políticamente correcto no
es una tarifa adecuada para nuestro país
joel hace muchos hace un tiempo el 23 de
septiembre del 2017 se me ocurrió
proponer una amnistía tributaria ahora
le estaba preguntando a rocío y la
amnistía produjo al final como 240 mil
millones y un 0.60 del producto interno
bruto en el primer año de aplicación de
la reforma incluso desde diciembre y
contra la amnistía se y se dijeron
barbaridades que era para beneficiar a
los ricos que sólo los ricos iban a
utilizarla y la verdad que fueron muchos
miles de costarricenses los que
aprovecharon esta oportunidad de
regularizar su situación y cuando se
hacen cálculos de lo que se hubiera
perdido por intereses el nivel de éxito
de la administración tributaria
la verdad es que la amnistía fue un buen
negocio y cómo te de que se trata de
ideas
yo quisiera dejar planteado lo que para
mí es una realidad y creo que se ha
comentado poco el impuesto al valor
agregado además de que debería tener una
tarifa superior no va a funcionar
adecuadamente porque no se conecta con
el impuesto sobre las utilidades en lo
que se refiere a asalariados y para que
las cosas funcionen en la vida tiene que
tener algún tipo de beneficio económico
hay un señor que dice que la plata no es
lo primero en la vida pero tampoco lo
segundo cuál es el beneficio económico
que tiene alguien que sé que casi que se
va a dar de pescozones con el barbero
porque no le da este la factura por
cobrándole él iba por el servicio de
corte de cabello ninguno es todo resultó
hacer que los asalariados solamente
tienen unos créditos ridículos no pueden
asociar ninguno de los gastos necesarios
para producir ese servicio que es
precisamente la prestación de trabajo en
relación de dependencia y entonces cuál
es el incentivo económico para que los
costarricenses asalariados e incluso los
que generan actividades lucrativas se
convierta en coadyuvantes de la
administración tributaria ninguno en
países civilizados donde simple y
sencillamente no estamos con este
sistema de carácter celular se puede
permitir como gasto tanto para
asalariados como para personas físicas
lucrativa cierto tipo de gastos
necesarios por ejemplo a mi edad los
gastos médicos son importantísimos es un
poco mantener el activo absolutamente de
preciado que es uno y en otros países
hay temas de recreación hay temas de
capacitación este desafortunadamente uno
no puede ir a trabajar en bermudas
entonces el día que todo el mundo tenga
que presentar declaración sobre las
utilidades y el día que comencemos a
mezclar a unir el impuesto de valor
agregado con el impuesto sobre las
utilidades y vamos a tener este un
impuesto mucho más productivo y con eso
este un país mejor
me pasé roberto perdón muchas gracias
a
[Música]